PDF has established itself as an
interchange format now did people get it
straight away as to what it was for was
it like PostScript was relatively a
howling roaring success from day one I
mean people gonna wait to buy postscript
in 1985
I'm not kidding they were pressing
checks into Steve Jobs and John Moores
hands saying how much how much I want
that now and I wanted quicker next year
wasn't like that with PDF it wasn't at
all
this was brought looks for me and the
most amusing but at the time scary way
in I think was the mid-90s my guess
would be it would be around about 1996 I
was visiting Adobe fairly regularly
doing lots of stuff with them on PDF and
so on and on this particular occasion
San Francisco immigration gets hold of
my passport and said purpose of visit
sir business or pleasure
I said well it's business Oh which
company you're visiting I said oh it's a
Adobe there in San Jose now oh that's
interesting so what what are you doing
with them I think it's the usual thing
that we all get used to is are you in
illegal immigrants are you actually
working for Adobe or are they paying you
and are you an employer no no it's just
we're interested in the same things
we're doing research and I'm just here
for a catch-up and various meetings with
peoples where we are with our projects
and he said but what kind of work do you
do with the dhobi sir and I said well
you may not have heard of it but they do
have a product a format if you like or
PDF and you can read it with a free
thing called Acrobat Reader and his face
froze oh yeah by money twist glasses off
put them down
and he turned my passport over what is
one size then sir that PDF what is it
for we just had heard similar things
from other people I just grinned I said
well do you want the five minutes to
offer another one our story I'll try and
keep it as brief as I can I said to I
look you know you'll probably exchange
documents with people and you've been
true you've been told you should use
this route PDF and use PDF as your
standard interchange form he said yeah
yeah that's quite right we can't
understand why we can't just sell each
other word files and I said well you
know some of the problems sending each
other word files
everybody's got a slightly different
version
and oh dear some people of running is on
Macintosh and not on PC and it doesn't
look this oh tell me about it you said
and I said well and then there's the
refuseniks who say WordPerfect is far
better and I absolutely refuse to use
anything from Microsoft or whatever oh
yeah we've got a few of those as well so
I said well the thing to remember is it
is about document exchange but it needs
to be ideally wanted a general solution
that's of high quality that could serve
all sorts of other use cases
just consider newspapers they want
something which is accurate and will
print out on a enormous sheet of paper
but yet they want to preview it at
smaller sizes and they want one document
to fit a whole load of sizes and
resolutions and to move seamlessly
between them taking quality all the time
that it doesn't start breaking up even
if you inflate it to the almost the size
of a barn door and I said newspapers
really really value that capability of
it and he said so like they have a route
to this PDF I said yes they got to have
a route to PDF and I said the other
people let me give you one more example
I said is that many of my colleagues
think it's just magic for output from a
program called AutoCAD as it you know
computer-aided design is used Glee's for
architects drawings could be used for
electronics engineering circuit diagrams
but the great thing for them is that
when you scale it up to a different size
it keeps the quality and by that I mean
that if it's drawn as a nice smooth
looking circle at this kind of size you
scale it up and the circle still looks
like a circle it doesn't start breaking
up into dots
it's a graphics model it's a
sophisticated scalable graphics model
inside the thing and that's why
engineers love it as well and now that
standard is get a great green cape
oprah's but
puts glasses back on so thank you so
much for that thank you thank you
passport back welcome to the United
States sir so I went away thinking I'm
not too surprised by that a lot of
people really don't get it don't
understand what it's for and I did think
I don't think it was quite on that trip
it might have been the next year that
I'd been involved with the dhobi on and
off for many years but particularly in
early 93 John Warnock and his colleague
Chuck - he chose us here at Natyam
through one of the first beta test sites
for pedia and I think it was maybe the
year after my interaction with the
immigration official and went to see
John I said first question was I said
John PDF how's it going he said David
it's a long long long uphill struggle
and I said yeah I can tell it's not
being kind of the overnight success that
PostScript was and he said no it isn't
and he said and if you were to ask me
how much I've spent already on PDF the
answer is 100 million dollars it dawned
on a straightaway if we want people to
adopt PDF you absolutely have to give
them a reader and it must be free the
moment you start charging for it people
will just refuse and will not use your
format so he said we've had to live with
that and he said I'll say it again we
are sure we are right so I went then
downstairs to talk to my colleague Ken
or I think was my liaison person at the
time and told him this story is that
David those of us on the technical side
of things we know that John and Chuck
are absolutely right but he said I have
to tell you that within this company as
jitters there's nerves because
particularly among the sales staff you
say they say we don't get any bonuses
out of pity if people don't understand
what it is you know and all that please
put me in charge of Photoshop I'll make
loads of those and money and bonuses out
but Terrell and I said yeah it's
understandable and having heard from
friends at Adobe about how being charge
of Photoshop we
deemed to be the real I thought well you
know the measure of PDF success is going
to be when if ever will its sales
revenues overtake those a Photoshop and
the answer for that I think it's in I've
got a book somewhere called the Adobe
story I think it was April 2004 when
finally PDF revenues overtook those from
pose of Photoshop it might visit around
about that time great hilarity the
Photoshop mob was I recall or on the
lower floors of the San Jose building
around about four to six or something
like that the PDF Acrobat PostScript
people were much higher up floor was 11
and 12 the top management John and
chucking song were up at the top of the
tower and I was told when I got there
that to great hilarity the moment the
sales results were announced in PDF and
over in Acrobat sales had overtaken
Photoshop large quantities of champagne
over sin from floor fall up to floor 12
with ribbons and congratulations guards
the message was the pressures on you now
have a nice day the other two canisters
are actually butane cylinders which were
discarded and they act kind of like a
gas capacitor the cool accumulators and
they store gas close to where it comes
out so that it can come out quickly